In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 11 on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Ephrosinos, the cook.
Saint Ephrosinos was a simple, minded peasant who took refuge in a monastery where he
was put to work in the kitchen as a schoolyon, doing the most thankless tasks.
He became the laughingstock of everyone, but bore it all with unshakable generosity of spirit.
There was a godly priest in the monastery who fervently desired that the Savior revealed
to him the good things he has in store for those who love him.
One night, as he slept, he had the sense of being carried to paradise into a garden full
of unutterable delights.
Ephrosinos was in the middle of the garden, tasting of the good things there and rejoicing
with the angels.
The priest went up to him and asked where they were.
Ephrosinos answered,
This is the dwelling place of God's elect that you have long to see for so many years.
And I am here because in his good pleasure God has forgiven my sins.
Gazing upon those unutterable good things that I has not seen nor ear heard neither have
entered into the heart of man, the priest observed that they were to some extent perceptible to
those who dwelt there.
So he asked Ephrosinos if he might take some of the fruit of the garden away with him,
whereupon Ephrosinos took three apples and put them in the priest's cloak.
Just then he was woken up by the sound of the call to matins.
As he came to himself from what he thought was a dream, he was amazed to find three apples
in his cloak, giving off a scent of unearthly sweetness.
He saw Ephrosinos in his usual place in the church and went up to him, begging him to
tell him where he had been during the night that it just passed.
Forgive me, Father, he answered, but I have been here all the time.
But as the devout priest pressed him earnestly not to conceal the blessings of God, the humble
Ephrosinos at last said,
It is true, Father, that I was in the garden where you saw the good things God has in store
for his elect and that it was the Lord's wish to show you this mystery through my unworthiness.
It was not long before the priest told everyone what he had witnessed and showed the apples
by way of proof.
The monks were encouraged through this sign to follow all the more zealously the path
of virtue and those who tasted the apples were healed of all kinds of disease.
As for the blessed Ephrosinos, he fled from the monastery.
For there was nothing he feared more than the praise of men.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.